[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
1er février
les cérémonies de voeux se termine pour
les élus jeudi soir c'était au tour du
président de saint quentin en yvelines
jean michel fourgous de se prêter à
l'exercice
à cette occasion valérie pécresse
présidente de la région a fait plusieurs
annonces concrètes
venus de toute la france ils se sont
mobilisés hier soir devant la prison de
fleury mérogis
les surveillants pénitentiaires
réclament notamment une revalorisation
des salaires
willy saïb délégué national force
ouvrière d'outre-mer travaillant à la
prison de bois d'arcy sera notre invité
la neige et la tempête gabriel ont causé
des dégâts dans le département nous
avons assisté aux réparations avec les
techniciens d'aînés 10 mais aussi aux
ateliers à l'occasion de la journée
européenne pour la protection des
données personnelles ou encore
dysfonctionnements dans les cantines
comme chaque vendredi coup d'oeil sur
l'actualité de la semaine dernière
cérémonie de voeux dans les yvelines
jeudi soir le président de 50 ans divine
s'est exprimé depuis le vélodrome à
montigny le bretonneux
il a dressé le bilan de 2018 et a
présenté les perspectives d'avenir
retour sur les principales annonces avec
wilfrid richie et patrick jacques de
dixmude
je suis là pour faire la révolution la
révolution robotique qui vous
soulagerait de tâches fastidieuses
je suis le cerveau de de jean-michel
fort gauche un robot pour cauet lui et
cette cérémonie de voeux 2010 9 à saint
quentin en yvelines un clin d'oeil aux
futurs et à ce qu'il réserve à
l'agglomération au cours de cette soirée
son président jean michel fourgous ainsi
fait plusieurs annonces transports
éducation sécurité des réalisations qui
commençons à voir le jour dans les
prochains mois malgré un contexte
économique compliqué on retiendra à la
possibilité pour les lycées de se doter
de tablettes pour remplacer les manuels
de seconde et de première
la mise en place d'un système de
location de vélos des tests de navettes
autonome ou encore une modernisation des
commissariats
ça concerne trois commissariats sweet
guyancourt je suis trappe celui
d'elancourt bien sûr avec une
organisation très différente beaucoup
plus moderne et la présidente de la
région d'apporter son soutien financier
notamment pour le doublement du pont de
la villedieu qui relie saint quentin en
yvelines à la vallée de chevreuse dans
les yvelines on sait bien que tout le
monde ne peut pas arriver au bureau en
transport en commun
et là c'est la passerelle de la
villedieu qui évita vrai point noir du
transport et qui sépare la ville
nouvelle de la vallée de chevreuse et
nous avons les moyens de nos ambitions
nous avons les moyens de financer tout
ça sans augmenter vos impôts pour la
quatrième année consécutive mieux relier
ces deux parties du territoire yvelinois
peut-être une façon de souligner une
volonté d'accueillir de nouvelles
communes au sein de l'agglomération
c'est vrai que la réussite de saint
quentin nous oblige à monthey en
communauté urbaine dont on n'aura plus
accès aux moyens européens aux moyens
nationaux je crois que nos élus sont
d'accord maintenant c'est un réglage
voilà fera pas avant les élections
municipales
je suis demandeur mais je sens qu'il
faut quand même démocratiquement quand
même attendre les élections municipales
je lance force ouvrière premier syndicat
chez les surveillants pénitentiaires a
appelé à la mobilisation pour obtenir
notamment une évolution statuaire le
premier rassemblement s'est déroulé il
hier à la maison d'arrêt de fleury
mérogis
bonjour willy saïb vous êtes le délégué
national force ouvrière d'outre-mer et
vous travaillez à la prison de bois
d'arcy
comment s'est passée la mobilisation et
hier soir avec les surveillants
pénitenciers venus de toute la france
m'a écouté hier soir effectivement il ya
une première mobilisation à la maison
d'arrêt de fleury mérogis
suite à l'appel de l'intersyndicale qui
représentent 70% du personnel de
l'administration pénitentiaire donc
c'est un premier jour de mobilisation de
façon à faire entendre madame la
ministre que les personnels demandent
cette fameuse catégorie b tout
simplement les personnels pénitentiaires
troisième force de sécurité derrière la
police et la gendarmerie réclament
notamment une revalorisation des
salaires
vous l'avez dit la catégorie b donc que
vous souhaitez de la fonction publique
ça correspond à une revalorisation des
salaires de 200 à 300 euros par mois
une proposition à laquelle nicole
belloubet a opposé une fin non de
recevoir car cela dit elle aurait pour
effet d'interdire le recrutement de
personnes n'ayant pas le baccalauréat
le passage en catégorie b impliquant
l'obligation de recruter au niveau bac
vous comprenez cette décision non pas du
tout parce que madame la ministre avait
reçu force ouvrière fin 2018
elle était favorable à cette catégorie b
et nous depuis plusieurs années à force
ouvrière on leur en réclament une
revalorisation salariale comme on est
aujourd'hui afin de pouvoir recruter
faire un meilleur recrutement et tout
devrait passer par là des militaires et
le statutaire donc à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui tenir sa faux discours
c'est un faux prétexte de la faire
croire qu'on aura du mal à recruter
c'est faux parce que quand on regarde
les statistiques au niveau de l'école de
l'administration pénitentiaire une
grande partie de ceux qui sont recrutés
sont des bacheliers donc à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui nous pour nous il est
inconcevable de
de laisser faire madame la ministre
force ouvrière effectivement comme vous
l'avez rappelé en est le premier
syndicat de l'administration
pénitentiaire on ait été élu sur un
programme est le point fort de ce
programme était la catégorie b donc
c'est pour ça que l'heure d'aujourd'hui
il ya une entente syndicale et nous
réclamons cette fameuse catégorie b
entre autres et quels sont justement vos
autres revendications
eh bien écoutez il ya la fusion des
grades passage automatique de
surveillants en surveillant brigadier
deux premiers surveillants a major il ya
le passage en catégorie a du corps de
commandement parce qu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui ce qu'ils veulent faire
c'est passé une partie du corps de
commandement catégorie a et laisser une
à de partitionnement catégorie b donc
pour nous il est inconcevable alors
d'aujourd'hui de laisser faire une telle
chose
donc voilà pour nous comme je vous ai
dit à l'heure d'aujourd'hui madame la
ministre
il faut qu'elles entendent qu'il ya 70%
du personnel qui réclame cette catégorie
b on ne peut pas à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
laisser faire et
les ententes de telles choses et
justement par rapport à la formation
elle est passée de 8 mois à 6 mois
c'est une de vos autres revendications
alors il ya effectivement la partie
indemnitaire mais il ya la partie
statutaire il ya la partie sécuritaire
est également la formation parce qu'à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui on peut pas dire
qu'on passe les formations de huit mois
six mois d'une part d'autre part ce
qu'on demande c'est une reclassification
des établissements on ne peut pas à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui il faut savoir
qu'on ne traite pas les détenus comme il
ya vingt ans en arrière
la population pénale a changé les
détenus des personnes détenues ont
changé ont d'autres comportements ils
sont beaucoup plus agressifs
donc c'est pour ça nous ce que nous
réclamons c'est des pistolets à
impulsion électrique pour certains
personnels avec une formation spécifique
bien sûr dans certains quartiers ce
qu'on réclame c'est les chiens qui
existe déjà mais ce qu'on demande c'est
qu' il soit plus exploitée parce que
malheureusement à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
ils sont sous-exploitées est ce qu'on
demande c'est voilà de façon à pouvoir
faire travailler les personnels de deux
conditions de bonnes conditions de
sécurité parce que ce n'est pas le cas
encore malheureusement aujourd'hui il ya
eu encore une tentative d'assassinât sur
un collègue et quelques jours qui a
failli qu'a failli perdre la vie
et il ya eu également
une évasion ou à l'armé lourde les
collègues se serait fait tirer dessus
comme des lapins donc ce qu'on demande à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est que madame
la ministre entendent et qu'on n'attende
pas qu'il y ait un drame malheureusement
pour pour que les nécessaires puissent
être faits et donc plus de recrutements
pour une meilleure sécurité
tout à fait vous savez on a beau
annoncer on a beau faire des annonces
parce que malheureusement d'administrer
puis et ses acolytes ils sont forts pour
faire des annonces mais malheureusement
faire les annonces et puis ne rien avoir
à côté c'est ça sert à strictement à
rien il ya eu effectivement il annonçait
2000 recrutement mais il faut regarder
combien d'un a perdu en cours de route
et comme je vous dis tant que ça ne
passe pas par l'un des militaires et le
statutaire on aura beaucoup de mal à
recruter
parce qu'il faut savoir que madame la
ministre qui ose dire que les
surveillants sont sont bien payés soit
savoir qu'un surveillant pénitentiaire à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est un smicard
vous enlever ces primes vous enlever ces
heures supplémentaires
un surveillant pénitentiaire c'est un
smic à ça c'est la réalité
donc alors comment comment laisser dire
madame la ministre que les surveillants
sont sont trop bien payé pour les passer
en catégorie catégorie b nous pour nous
c'est inconcevable donc un salaire à
revoir des heures beaucoup d'heures vous
travailler le dimanche
vous avez des vacances imposées c'est un
métier qui m'attire plus à leurs deux
fois il faut dire les choses honnêtement
c'est pas un métier qu'on fait par
vocation
on le fait pour venir chercher la
sécurité de l'emploi donc à surveillants
pénitentiaires payer effectivement quand
on regarde un surveillant pénitentiaire
est payé entre 2000 et 2002 sans euro il
n'y a pas de souci mais il faut pas
regarder uniquement à la fin de la fiche
de paye il faut regarder le nombre
d'heures supplémentaires qui l'a fait au
détriment de sa vie de famille pour
avoir un salaire convenable et si ses
revendications ne sont pas entendues
qu'allez vous faire vous allez faire
durer ce mouvement écoutait le mouvement
va durer le teint qui va qu'il faudra
l'intersyndicale va encore se retrouver
le lundi 4 donc à partir de là
des décisions seront prises mais
effectivement s'il faut partir en
mouvement au niveau national ça sera
fait cette mobilisation arrive un an
après le mouvement de protestation qui
avait paralysé pendant près de trois
semaines toutes les prisons françaises
le conflit avait pris fin après la
signature par l'ufap unsa fo est
maintenant devenu le premier syndicat
vous irait jusqu'à là vous aussi
paralysie totale si madame b loubet ne
changent pas d'avis écoutez comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure force
ouvrière on est le syndicat majoritaire
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on est des élus
par rapport à une feuille de route par
rapport à des engagements que nous avons
pris auprès du personnel
et s'il faut aller jusque là eh ben si
les personnages décide qu'il va falloir
durcir le mouvement aller jusqu'au bout
dans sera prêt à aller jusqu'au bout
merci willis arrive d'être venu je le
rappelle vous êtes le délégué national
force ouvrière d'outre-mer et vous
travaillez à la maison d'arrêt de bois
d'arcy
merci à vous tout de suite on passe au
résumé de l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
la neige mais aussi les rafales de vents
de la tempête gabriel ont causé des
dégâts dans le département des chutes
d'arbres ont également affecté le réseau
d'électricité au plus fort de la crise
sept mille deux cents foyers yvelinois
ont été privés de courant 30 agents
d'aînés dix ont été mobilisés pour
assurer le retour du courant
exemple avec cette opération mercredi à
orphin mélanie poquet pour les moyens
techniques
nous sommes actuellement à orphin
communes touchées par les coupures
d'électricité suite à la tempête gabriel
deux des câbles de moyenne tension sont
tombés cette nuit les équipes des dix
sont sur place sept mille deux cents
personnes étaient coupés d'électricité à
4 heures du matin quelle est la
situation à la mi-journée à la mi
journée nous avons dans les yvelines
encore 850 personnes qui sont privées
d'électricité
ce qui veut dire que on a rétabli la
très grande majorité de nos clients
déjà ce matin 75 % des clients étaient
déjà avait retrouvé l'électricité
actuellement de vos employés sont en
train de réparer les deux câbles tombés
cette nuit
quelles sont leurs actions qu'est ce
qu'ils font nos agents sont arrivés sur
place le plus vite possible pour mettre
en sécurité la zone et réparer les
câbles dans les plus brefs délais
avec tout un matériel adapté à cette
situation
et quelle est la durée d'une telle
intervention alors cette intervention
dure en moyenne autour de trois heures
le temps justement de mettre la zone en
sécurité de monter sur les poteaux à
l'échelle afin de reconnecter les câbles
cassé et de remettre le courant pour
l'ensemble des clients concernés est ce
qu'il ya des risques
alors évidemment nous tenons à rappeler
qu'il ne faut absolument pas s'approcher
des câbles électriques tombés au sol
restez bien à distance éloigner vos
enfants de ces câbles nos équipes
arrivent sur place et interviennent le
plus vite possible pour mettre en
sécurité
nos installations et réparer le courant
30 techniciens d'aînés dix sont
actuellement en intervention dans tout
les yvelines le courant devrait être
rétabli d'ici ce soir
la pluie a remplacé la neige avec une
température minimale de 2 degrés et une
maximale de 9 degrés pour aujourd'hui et
samedi
mais dimanche matin soyez vigilants la
neige devrait revenir quelques flocons
sont attendus indique météo france
le 30 mars prochain le breakbeat entrera
en vigueur mais aujourd'hui encore les
termes ne sont pas connus pour
accompagner au mieux les entreprises
françaises qui seront concernés une
réunion se tenait à la cci de versailles
en début de semaine en présence de la
douane et la direccte reportage de
mélanie poké et patrick jacques de
dixmude accompagné s'informer malgré le
flou à deux mois de l'entrée en vigueur
du bric site les entreprises
s'interrogent sur le futur j'ai besoin
de savoir où je vais mettre les pieds
comme l'angleterre et mes fournisseurs
en angleterre n'en savent pas plus que
moi je viens prendre un peu la
température du continent
l'administration française et connaître
mes obligations et devoirs au coeur de
cette réunion le scénario le plus
compliqué un brick site sans accord le
royaume uni deviendrait un pays tiers
l'angleterre devient un pays sur lequel
il n'y a plus aucun n'accord donc on
repart sur une page blanche teint et que
nous n'avons aucun accord pour avoir des
accords équivalents à ceux que nous
avons avec certains prix vis des pays
privilégiés comme la norvège ou la
suisse où les états unis vont nous
demander au minimum dix ans de travail
pour arriver à mettre en place un
certain nombre d'accords il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises du final qui font du
commerce avec le royaume uni parce que
c'est un partenaire privilégié d'un
point de vue économique mais jusqu'à
présent elle ne faisait pas forcément de
grand export elle faisait de l'intra
communautaire c'est à dire qu'elle
n'était pas soumise aux règles de douane
dans les yvelines
elles sont plus d'une centaine notamment
des petites entreprises à être concernés
par ces échanges intracommunautaires si
aucun accord n'est trouvé les droits de
douane seront rétablis ces entreprises
arrivent vont devoir apprendre un métier
vous faire faire cette prestation par un
professionnel de la douane et donc elles
doivent c'est celle ci qui sont le plus
impacté par le break site puisque celles
qui font déjà de l'import et de l'export
en réalité ça sera un pays de plus dans
leur portefeuille export ou encore le
coeur de cible des douanes les
entreprises exportant télé pme avec un
mot clé
l'anticipation il reste deux mois avant
la mise en place du bric site mouvement
de contestation dans les établissements
scolaires à l'origine le nouveau
fonctionnement pour les cantines des
collèges yvelinois depuis le 1er janvier
2019 le conseil départemental des
yvelines a chargé la sodexo de fournir
les repas de 116 établissements non sans
dysfonctionnements notamment dans le
collège de la mauldre à maule
les précisions de nicolas d'andry une
pétition avec 400 signatures et un
boycott de la cantine voilà la situation
au collège de la mauldre à maule
conséquence d'une baisse de la qualité
des repas sur lons les élèves pain
congelé des charançons dans les
lentilles un constat des élèves et de
leurs parents dont se défend le
département chargé de la gestion des
collèges
quand un de vos confrères
explique qu' on a servi un enfant qui
portent témoignage du fait qu'on a servi
des lentilles charançonné lorsque le
cuistot s'est aperçu qu'il y avait des
charançons dans les lentilles
naturellement il les a pas servis donc
elles ne sont jamais arrivés sur la
table des enfants donc aucun appui à
manger face à ces dysfonctionnements le
conseil départemental des yvelines
plaide le temps d'adaptation face à ce
nouveau mode de fonctionnement
la sélection c'est notre associé donc la
sodexo ne peut pas ne pas remplir ce
pourquoi elle s'est associée avec nous
donc il n'y a aucune inquiétude
l'inquiétude n'est pas matériel nous
avons besoin de temporalité moi je pense
que fin février tout ça ne sera plus
qu'un mauvais souvenir
sachant que comme toujours dans ces
systèmes de restauration collective y
aura ici ou là des problèmes qui
resurgiront régulièrement et qu on
corrigera automatiquement
ce nouveau mode de fonctionnement passe
par la société d'économie mixte c midi
avec des obligations fixées par le
département à son partenaire la sodexo
elle lundi était la journée consacrée à
la protection des données personnelles
il s'agissait de la première journée de
sensibilisation depuis l'entrée en
vigueur du règlement général sur la
protection des données jusqu alors les
données personnelles étaient divulgués
et partager sans le consentement au
préalable des consommateurs et sans même
qu'il ne soit au courant
nous avons participé pour l'occasion à
des ateliers d'initiation aux nouvelles
technologies à l'espace net public de
voisins-le-bretonneux pour les seniors
ils sont des cibles privilégiées
la journée mondiale de protection des
données est l'occasion de sensibiliser
les personnes danger menace de la
cybercriminalité et les seniors sont des
cibles potentielles pour faciliter
l'accès aux nouvelles technologies et
développer les usages du web
plusieurs modules étaient proposés à
l'espace net public de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est apprendre à
bien différencier tous les
et tout ce qu'on peut nous proposer en
termes de serveurs donc de cloud de bien
protéger ses données au niveau même de
son ordinateur smartphone tablette
numérique
on a vu par exemple ne jamais laisser un
disque dur lorsqu'on jette un ordinateur
à la déchetterie les données ont changé
elles vont aujourd'hui bien au-delà de
nos simples coordonnées dans un annuaire
téléphonique à l'ère du numérique les
données personnelles englobe nos
contacts nos lectures nos photos que les
seniors apprennent à gérer avec le cloud
au début que j'étais à la retraite j'ai
suivi le formation sur la photo je
comment se servir d'armes nature
également on a toujours des doutes quand
on doit se servir d'un réalisateur donc
on a toujours peur de mal faire mais
années qui arrivent on nous oblige à
utiliser un ordinateur internet
il faut pas que les personnes de plus de
60 ans soit laissé sur le bord du chemin
côté du chemin parce qu'ils ne seront
pas utilisées ou vous recevoir des et
news que ce soit d or acc que ça soit
des du fichier et les personnes âgées
sont des victimes potentielles
d'autres ateliers sont proposés jusqu'au
14 février plus de 2,5 milliards
d'octets de données sont créés chaque
jour
[Musique]
c'est l'une des réponses du gouvernement
à la crise des gilet jaune
emmanuel macron engage un grand débat
national permettant à toutes et à tous
de débattre des questions essentielles
pour les français la mise en place d'une
grande concertation de terrain a
commencé exemple à villiers-le-bel avec
nos confrères de via grand paris autour
de ces tables une quarantaine
d'habitants de villiers-le-bel
rassemblés pour une réunion un peu
particulière le conseil de quartier
habituel a laissé place au grand débat
national souhaité par le gouvernement
compte tenu de la situation ça nous
paraissait utile de consacrer ses
premiers conseils de quartier à ceux à
ce débat national
je pense qu'on paye le fait qu'il n'ya
pas eu d'élection présidentielle
c'est-à-dire la campagne entre le
retrait du président hollande et puis
les mésaventures de françois fillon il
ya quasiment pas eu de débat si on se
souvient de cette présidentielle
bon après tout qu on a un débat sur les
questions de fond deux ans après nous
l'avoir deux ans après que quelques pas
du tout dans la salle peu de nouveaux
visages essentiellement les habitués de
ces réunions régulières par petits
groupes les habitants aborde les quatre
thématiques proposées par le président
de la république fiscalité dépenses
publiques transition écologique
démocratie et citoyenneté organisation
de l'état et des services publics
l'objectif permettre au plus grand
nombre d'exprimer des idées et des
revendications ne pouvoir d'achat oui il
fait face à l'augmentation des
les retraités après 45 minutes de
discussion c'est le moment de mettre en
commun leurs doléances
moi je les transporte tous les jours des
catastrophes
l'ensemble des contributions des
habitants vont être transmises à la
préfecture
bien que présents certains restent
sceptiques quant à l'efficacité du grand
débat national
malheureusement quand on vit à villiers
le bel on ne se sent pas considéré donc
je sais pas si je sais par pardon jean
céryhin doc
j'aimerais y croire monsieur macron s'il
vous plaît écoutez nous
au total cinq réunions de ce type ont
été organisées par la ville dans les
yvelines à louveciennes bruno le maire
était présent hier soir dans le cadre du
grand débat
invité par la député de la 4e
circonscription marie lebey qu il est
venu échanger avec les habitants
chaque vendredi nous ouvrons les
archives de tv soixante dix huit pour
notre séquence ça s'est passé
aujourd'hui retour en 2017 lors de la
défaite de françois xavier bellamy aux
élections législatives
l'actuel tête de liste aux européennes
s'étaient inclinés face à la république
en marche
douche froide pour les républicains dans
la première circonscription des yvelines
à droite depuis 1963 le bastion a cédé
sous la vague de la république en marche
françois-xavier bellamy n'a pas réussi à
inverser la tendance du premier tour où
il avait réalisé seulement 27,49 % des
suffrages contre 42 15 % pour le
candidat de la république en marche
didier baichère malgré une belle
remontée l'homme politique de 31 ans
s'inclinent finalement 2 827 voix
j'espérais au soir du premier tour et
j'en étais convaincu que nous pouvions
rattraper le retard pourtant important
qui nous séparait de notre concurrent
dans marche c'était possible et on l'a
prouvé
on a reçu 7000 voix de plus dans l'entré
deux tours mais on s'arrête voilà sur le
seuil de cette victoire parce que je
crois profondément c'est que nous vivons
est un phénomène national sur lequel
finalement on avait bien peu de prise il
suffit de constater les autres scores
des yvelines et de voir que là on fait
l'un des meilleurs scores de toutes les
yvelines aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment
une fierté
la défaite de françois xavier bellamy
est également un coup dur pour le député
dvd sortant françois de mazières
mais le maire de versailles qui avait
remporté la circonscription en 2012 avec
56% des voix est prêt à travailler a
conseillé le nouveau député
je lui ai proposé tout alors souvent
rapidement envie d'y aller
aussi nous sommes important de suivre en
tant que parlementaire c'est évident et
il n'y a aucune raison à partir du
moment où des électeurs ont décidé
qu'ils étaient eux d'écouter la presse
processeurs des yvelines qu'on ne
travaille pas et puis qu'on travaille
qu'on soit plus positive pour cette
belle sont consultés après l'annoncé
officielle dans sa permanence de
campagne place charreaux à versailles
didier baichère analyse avec ses
soutiens les scores dans les différentes
communes
dans le détail le candidat l'emportent
de 27 points à montigny le bretonneux et
de 41 points lui en cour à versailles
c'est françois-xavier bellamy qui
l'emportent ils totalisent plus de 60
29% des suffrages
je pensais pas honnêtement que
versailles remontrer autant par rapport
à la semaine dernière mais d'un autre
côté la semaine dernière c'était
vraiment une surprise d'être au coude à
coude sur versailles donc je pense que
j'avais beaucoup de gens qui n'avaient
pas voté la semaine dernière donc très
bien pour mon concurrent d'avoir remonté
pour lui à versailles comme ça ça
partage un peu la peine avec lui après
avoir savouré sa victoire dans sa
permanence didier baichère se remettra
en marche dès ce mercredi pour ses
premiers pas à l'assemblée nationale
c'est la fin de ce cette 8e 2 vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre application ou sur
notre site internet
retour de l'information dans le 7-8 tu
en as lundi à 18h passer un excellent
week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]